Joe is with us in Arizona hi Joe welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show
I'm Azure Andy thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up so I got
into a car loan this year right now the
debt is that $22,000 and I'm trying to
figure out what's my next move in it I
should sell this vehicle
what is your household income forty five
thousand yes you should start the car
okay and what is the car worth probably
so I just got into a car accident
somebody ran a red light and t-boned me
so currently I've I'm working on getting
an appraisal but I'm not too sure at
this point probably I'm gonna guess
fourteen thousand oh but the cars gonna
be repaired by the person who hits you
right correct okay so the that's already
taken care of but I I don't know why
fourteen thousand you just bought the
car true but I'm just making an
estimation because I don't know how much
of the value was lost because of that
accident
oh not anywhere near that you're
guessing yeah okay so is the car has
been repaired correct okay well just
jump on Kelly Blue Book and see what a
private sale is okay and it's gonna be
somewhere around there I mean you may
have lost a thousand dollars in value or
two thousand dollars in value but you
didn't lose eight thousand dollars in
value so what do you think this car is
actually worth on Kelly Blue Book you
have any idea um 20 about nineteen to
twenty thousand okay so how are you
going to come up with the difference
well I've been my savings is about a
thousand dollars right now
I was hoping on building up a bigger
savings by buying a hoopty and then not
having to worry about that payment that
way I can pay off the difference during
that time period okay all right
how's your credit credits good why don't
you just go borrow the three or four
thousand
but and then used that coverage then to
cover the difference and then you can
get the car sold so if the car sells for
eighteen and in you owe 22 you need four
thousand but dollars to be able to get
the title right correct okay so we need
a loan set up not you have to take the
loan today but you need the loan
arranged for $4,000 in order to have a
buyer come up and hand you a check for
18 then you put the house on the market
the car on the market and get it sold
now your four thousand dollars in debt
stood at twenty two thousand and now
we're moving in the right direction and
of course in somewhere in there is the
saving up and getting the hooptie and
that kind of stuff so you got something
so you're not walking but yeah start
with the hooptie and then you can move
you can move up rapidly for what your
car payments are I mean your car
payments are ridiculous